Okay, this person is writing about their caretaker of a person. So this is why it's written in the third person.
Lisa is concerned and not sure about the growth in her neck. Her hospice there's told her that it's from the steroids, but she's worried.
Should I send a photo? Yes, you could send a photo with an e-mail and we should do another cheek swab. So that's what would be the appropriate thing. So it's always good if there's something going on physically that you want me to see.
And you want me, if you're doing a cheek swab, then send that just like tests. Okay, you got some blood tests back. I'm not going to interpret your blood tests, but send me the blood work with your cheek swab stuff. So send that to me, send it in the colors clinic, or you can send it at labs at colors clinic.
So yes, send it a photo, send it to your cheek swab. Also do you recommend doing a cheek swab? Yes, do that. She's been able to do, had been able to do coffee animals until a week ago, but now she needs help.
And it's so very painful to get up and down from bed or recliner, etc.
And I haven't heard any of this and I am very limited to help her.
I have been assisted until illness and injury prevented me from helping wondering what alternatives we have to give it to animals. So first of all, I would look on the member site and look at the easy peasy way of doing a coffee animal.
That doesn't require you to lay down. You can stand up in the shower and do the animal in the shower and step out and use the toilet.
So look at the easy peasy way of doing a coffee animal if you're going to do coffee animals. Now certainly, if it's too difficult physically to do a coffee animal that you can do castoral packs over the liver or just heat packs over the liver can be beneficial as well.
So don't cause an injury trying to do a coffee animal. How often do you recommend using the PEMF machine? So if you have a PEMF machine, I would say once or twice a day, I think this is supposed to say more than two times per day.
I would say no, I would say once or twice a day with the PEMF machine.
Are there any natural supplements that could help with pain?
Look back at some of the other past Zoom calls, but your best natural supplements that are going to be for paid is going to be CBD.
Touric, which is your curcumin.
And then all your flavonoids, which will be your white bill willobark, your Boswellia, your green tea extract, your Resveratrol, things that are in our product called the clear inflame product.
The clear inflame has really all those all those things, your number one natural thing for paid is going to be THC, but a lot of people don't make don't like the way THC makes them feel because that's the active component of marijuana.
And I returned to normal stature with this treatment.
I'm not sure what you mean by normal stature.
Can you heal by doing everything you're doing? Obviously, God's in charge of your healing. It's our responsibility to do everything you possibly can to help yourself.